[Musique]
salut à tous il y à quelques temps un
vidéaste assez connu une bulle qui
travaille pour mediapart et qui se
revendique communiste a réalisé une
vidéo traitant du communisme et de
l'objectivité dans cette vidéo que je
vous invite à regarder avant de
continuer celle ci il passe un certain
temps à essayer de réhabiliter l'idée
communiste malgré les 100 millions de
morts causées par cette idéologie en
tentant d'expliquer les errements du
passé et en essayant de montrer que le
capitalisme n'est pas tout blanc non
plus mais le problème c'est une bonne
partie des arguments utilisés sont
historiquement et moralement douteux et
certains sont même parfaitement
condamnable c'est pourquoi j'ai décidé
de faire cette vidéo en réponse
mais tout d'abord quelques remarques sur
les 100 millions de morts qu'on attribue
au communisme car il va en être question
dans l'argumentaire du zune en fait on
est plutôt autour de 80 85 millions de
morts
même si à cette échelle ça ne change pas
grand chose parmi ces morts il y a
plusieurs catégories les mort
involontaire due à l'incompétence
économique les morts de faim typiquement
par exemple lors du grand bond en avant
en chine
et puis il ya les morts volontaires les
meurtres de masse par exécution lors de
la terreur rouge lors des purges les
gens n'auront goulag ou en déportation
dans des zones inhabitables
parmi ces morts volontaires on ne peut
pas tout citer on peut tout de même
mentionner les 2 5 millions de personnes
tuant quatre ans par le régime khmer
rouge soit un quart de la population
tout de même dans des conditions dignes
des camps nazis
ajoutons à cela 2 5 autres millions de
morts lors de la grande famine de 1932
car cette famille n'a été provoqué on a
retiré aux paysans toutes leurs réserves
y compris les réserves de semences
alors que dans le même temps l'urss
exporter du blé pour industrialiser le
pays
et enfin on peut ajouter les 1,5 million
de morts lors des grandes purges de 1937
rien qu'avec ces quelques grands
événements on a au minimum 6 million et
demi de morts premier argument pour
tenter de réhabiliter les militants
communistes leur aveuglement sur le rss
serait la faute de la direction du parti
communiste
en rigolant évidemment pierre desproges
non seulement les communistes mangent
les enfants mais en plus il manque
d'objectivité
alors ça c'est un vieux reproche
certainement lié au centralisme
démocratique en vigueur aux grandes
heures du parti communiste français à
l'époque de la guerre froide par exemple
les militants communistes avaient en
effet tendance à être tous d'accord
entre eux et surtout avec la direction
d'ailleurs quand ce n'était pas le cas
on leur proposait de faire leur
autocritique
ou alors on les exclut et du parti alors
oui il ya une certaine époque si vous
demandiez à des militants communistes
leur avis sur le printemps de prague les
dissidents soviétiques ou le camarade
staline l'homme qu'ils aimaient le plus
il risquait d'être pas bien objectif
mais bon on en est plus là mais les
militants de base n'a jamais eu besoin
d'une hiérarchie aux ordres de moscou
pour s'aveuglent et dès les débuts de
l'urss avant même la création du parti
communiste
les militants voulaient y croire et
refuser de voir la nature du régime il
faut se rappeler que la scission du
parti socialiste en 1920 qui a donné
naissance au parti communiste est dû au
refus de certains socialistes de prêter
allégeance aux soviétiques
parce que dès le début il y avait des
échos sur ce qui se passait dans le pays
il faut aussi se rappeler que dès les
premières années du régime soviétique
des opposants russes de toutes
obédiences y compris socialistes ont
dénoncé la dérive totalitaire de lénine
et la terreur rouge qu'il a mis en place
si les militants communistes français
voulez vraiment savoir ce qui se passait
en urss il le pouvait et puis quand on
est communistes
il n'y a pas besoin d'être militant au
pcf pour se leurrer dans les années 70
des groupuscules gauchistes ont éclos
certains ont fait allégeance à mao
les maoïstes français voyez la
révolution culturelle chinoise comme
summum de la révolution libertaire et
démocratique
alors que ce n'était qu'une
instrumentalisation de la jeunesse
chinoise par mao dans sa guerre interne
contre d'autres dirigeants du parti les
militants maoïstes français se sont
leurrés par volonté de croire à la même
époque d'autres venir et trotsky et chez
les trotskistes justement edwy plenel
actuel employeur du nul est alors membre
de la ligue communiste n'a eu besoin
d'aucune direction stalinienne en 1972
pour justifier le meurtre de civils
israéliens par des terroristes
palestiniens
sa foi dans le communisme lui a suffi
encore une fois les communistes ont cru
aux différents paradis socialiste
pendant 70 ans
s'ils ont défendu d indéfendables c'est
avant tout à cause de leur volonté de
croire et ceux qui avaient la capacité
d'ouvrir les yeux les ont couverts il ya
eu des périodes propices au réveil qui
ont vu nombre de militants quitter le
navire
comme par exemple le rapport
khrouchtchev ou encore la répression des
soulèvements pro-démocratie à budapest
et à prague
ensuite via un extrait documentaire
musulmane la parole à henri malberg un
ancien dirigeant communiste dès qu'il
est question du communisme c'est pour
faire son procès en procès qui au regard
des atrocités commises par le camp d'en
face peut sembler injuste profondément
injuste d'autant plus qu'on est depuis
des dizaines d'années tout ça sahamies
siècle un demi-siècle après on ne parle
on reproche pas aux américains hiroshima
on a fini de reprocher aux allemands au
shit fini son pays
on a fini de reprocher la
non-intervention qu'un crime à léon blum
on ne parle même plus parce qu'ils ont
élu un homme noir et c'est très
important de la guerre du vietnam et de
la guerre de corée où on balançait des
microbes c'est invraisemblable ce que
l'impérialisme a fait dans cette eau ne
parle plus des deux ou trois cent mille
algérien assassiné par l'armée française
sous la direction de socialistes henri
malberg reproche tout et n'importe quoi
tout le monde
il multiplie les citations de faits sans
lien entre eux pour noyer le poisson
pour dire que tout le monde habitants
sur les mains d'une façon ou d'une autre
mais quel rapport entre la
non-intervention de blum en espagne en
36 et la guerre du vietnam
aucun alors que les crimes du communisme
réel ont en commun d'avoir été perpétrés
au nom de l'idée communiste malberg
reprend aussi de vieux éléments de
propagande
il accuse les usa d'avoir utilisé des
armes bactériologiques en corée alors
que c'est faux
à l'époque les usa avaient même demandé
une enquête à l'onu pour prouver qu'il
ne s'agissait que de propagande
nord-coréenne mais l'urss a mis son veto
lors du vote probablement pour éviter à
ses alliés nord-coréen de passer pour
des cons là malberg nous fait une belle
démonstration de la persistance de la
croyance en à fait erronée par
aveuglement idéologique et puis il ya
l'élément le plus absurde de toute
l'argumentation malberg nous dit qu'on a
pardonné au ju jitsu allemand c'est vrai
maître allemand c'est une nationalité on
a choisi par être communiste c'est une
croyance à laquelle on adhère
volontairement et si on a pardonné aux
allemands que je sache on n'a toujours
pas pardonné aux nazis
c'est marrant que c'est toujours les
nazis qui ont les movie roule nous
sommes en 1955
on peut avoir une deuxième chance merci
bref malberg illustre assez bien le cas
de ces communistes qui acceptent le
passé uniquement contraint et forcé mais
qui continue à se leurrer au nom de
l'idéologie
car aujourd'hui encore il suffit qu'un
régime autoritaire se réclament de la
gauche et certains discours vaguement
marxiste pour être absous de tous ces
errements par exemple cuba ou le
venezuela
pourtant le discours nsv lien par
exemple est le même que celui qui avait
cours du temps du bloc de l'est
tous les problèmes du pays viennent d'
éléments ennemis du régime fatalement
fasciste et de droite alliée à des pays
étrangers fatalement capitaliste et
impérialiste comme le dit le proverbe il
n'est de pire aveugle que celui qui ne
veut voir ensuite eu il reprend la
parole et embraye sur un dernier
argument le problématique et mon avis
non on va sortir quelques chiffres
chaque année dans le monde le
capitalisme qu'est le mode de production
dominant sur la planète organisée si
bien la distribution d'eau que 8
millions de personnes en manque et en
meurt presque lui millions de personnes
meurent elles parce que le capitalisme
les laisse crever de faim alors qu'avec
ce qui produit pourrait nourrir deux
fois la population mondiale
ajoutez à ça les trois millions cinq
cent mille personnes qui décèdent de
maladies que l'on sait soigner ça nous
fait un million de morts par an en cinq
ans on a 100 millions
comme dans le livre noir on entre là
dans l'argument comptable alors il ya
des gens que ça gêne c'est pas parce que
l'ennemi a tué 50 personnes et vous
seulement 49 que vous êtes normalement
supérieure
personnellement ça ne me gêne pas pour
peu qu'on compare ce qui est comparable
et le problème dans le cas du nul
c'est qu'on mélange de choses très
différentes les 20 millions de morts
annuels qu'il attribue au capitalisme
n'ont pas été assassiné à la rigueur
c'est une forme de non-assistance à
personne en danger ou d'homicide
involontaire mais il n'y a pas de
volonté de commettre des meurtres de
masse de la part du capitalisme il n'y a
pas de politburo du cac 40 qui a décider
de l'exécution de 20 millions de
personnes par an s'il est mort dans le
système capitaliste sont involontaires
par contre dans les 100 millions de
morts du communisme
on l'a vu une part non négligeable est
dû à la volonté de tuer ce sont des
meurtres est le seul moyen de comparer
des morts volontaires et involontaires
c'est d'abolir la notion
d'intentionnalité et c'est là le fond du
problème peut-on mettre sur le même plan
moral des gens qui meurent parce qu'ils
n'ont pas de quoi acheter un médicament
et des gens qui meurent au goulag
si oui alors on abolit l'intentionnalité
et toutes les morts se valent avec
toutes les conséquences que ça peut
avoir derrière un décidant exécuté en
urss vaut un mort de faim en afrique
vaut un accident par mort du travail en
france où un juif gazée à auschwitz et
dans ce cas le pire régime n'est pas le
plus cruel le plus violent où le plus
discriminatoire et celui qui a fait le
plus de morts selon votre comptabilité
personnelle et selon usuelles c'est de
très loin avec ses 20 millions de morts
par an le capitalisme est par contre
coupe le nazisme avec ses 25 millions de
morts sur 12 ans est bien moins pire
car oui l'argumentation du jules
involontairement ouvre la voie à la
réhabilitation de toutes les idéologies
génocidaires au passage heureusement
pour résulte que la haine sociale n'est
pas condamné contrairement à la haine
raciale
parce que sinon minimiser autant de
morts lui aurait valu un procès
rappelons nous que jean marie le pen a
été condamné pour avoir minimisé la
violence de l'occupation allemande
bref j'espère que cette vidéo vous aura
apporté un éclairage alternatif et moins
manichéen que celle du zune si c'est le
cas et bien je vous invite à la partager
et à mettre un coup double moi je vous
donne rendez-vous pour une prochaine
vidéo
d'ici là je vous dis portez vous bien et
à la prochaine
[Musique]